take a look at this from Daily Mail
Democrats demand a national security
investigation into Saudi Arabia's stake
in Twitter under Elon Musk senator says
Kingdom wants to repress political
speech and impact U.S politics boy was
that fast
the Saudi Prince has had a major stake
in Twitter for a very long time and not
a single one of these Psychopaths batted
and I until now with Elon Musk taking
over there there was a tweet that said
how long until all of a sudden the
Democrats the butma private company
Democrats changed their mind and say we
need regulation and insight and
oversight into this well here you go
yeah Robert Reich immediately with the
Elon thing like let him on like not but
just set him off like Rob all of a
sudden now he's screaming about Elon
being an oligarch and we need to break
it up like he never mentioned that I
mean like Jack Dorsey wasn't yeah wait
until they find out about Tick Tock in
China wait until they find out about
Facebook and you know the Department of
Homeland Security if you just find out
what found out about right now again
this is clearly an attempt to punish
Elon Musk as he is presenting an
opportunity to fight back against all of
this nonsense and provide the best ideas
to rise to the top that's an idea that's
scaring the crap on the individuals who
have a monopoly on ignorance and violent
and of course is the state absolutely I
mean the Saudi public investment fund
they've you know publicly they've
invested
um in this live golf tour recently you
know they were early investors in Uber
you know the pif has their hands in a
lot of American companies that's not
really a new thing
um you know but I found it interesting
that the doj launched a criminal
investigation into Tesla last week you
know coincidentally you know the the
week of the closing of the Twitter deal
into Tesla's you know full safe driving
or full self-driving capabilities so I
thought that timing was a bit more than
suspect that the week the Twitter deal
closes the doj launch is not a civil
investigation a criminal investigation
you know with potential jail time uh for
uh Tesla Executives can I can I just ask
everybody if they have their shot
glasses ready so I can say Civil War now
there you go should it give it should
have given you a second
um we had this tweet from Chris Murphy
says today I'm requesting the committee
on foreign investment which reviews
Acquisitions of U.S businesses by
foreign foreign buyers to conduct an
investigation into the National Security
implications of Saudi Arabia purchase of
Twitter he already had the stake in
Twitter and the reason why I bring up
those magic words is because when the
Democrats Overlook or defend things like
foreign influence in in our social media
platforms when it favors them and then
seek to weaponize the US government or
the doj when when all of a sudden that
power shifts
we can't function that way it's not it's
not possible for this country to exist
if one political party is actively
weaponizing law enforcement and the
weight of the federal government to
Target their political Rivals and that's
the only way it ever goes eventually
confidence shatters and it doesn't have
to be civil war like people charging at
each other that's not how the first
Civil War started it can be a peaceful
divorce would you consider what John
Slater what Gandhi did with India a
Civil War when they just stopped saying
sorry Britain just words passive
Disobedience we're not following it
could be that my beef with the national
divorce crowd I'm open to that concept
but I think that fundamentally
misunderstands the nature of the radical
left they they're never going to let red
States just go off and do their own
thing the left they they get off on
rubbing your nose in it they get off on
lording it over you as we're seeing now
like they they I mean like just look at
the I mean one example out of many I
mean look at
um you know look at the the way that the
the
um you know gay pride movement has
evolved over the past 20 30 40 years you
know it started as you know just you
know do what you want in your own
bedroom to civil unions to gay marriage
to the pride movement to transgender to
grooming children it's about rubbing it
in the faces of their political enemies
and so I just I think that the concept
that we're going to have this uh very
civil National divorce I think that's a
bit naive nothing civil but but at the
same time I agree with your point there
they are there are status that love to
tell people what to do but when you have
a centralized big Federal bureaucratic
government you have a vessel to allow
them to do that and I think we're seeing
the results of that and I think we're
seeing such uh you know divisiveness so
many people fighting each other because
of other people pushing their ideas onto
other individuals that's why I think a
decentralization a moving away from a
big federal government and enforcing
state governments could be something
like a peaceful divorce that that could
eventually happen in a way where it's
not really a divorce but at the same
time we don't have other people forcing
ideas onto other people because there's
no vessel in order to do it adequately
and that's why I would always argue
because I am for uh you know a you know
a peaceful divorce but a peaceful
divorce in a way that doesn't rely on
the federal government telling States
what to do states deciding for
themselves what they should be doing
themselves a limited federal government
regarding this Saudi this Saudi uh news
so this is the same investment Saudi
Investment that was in Twitter before
the acquisition yep so here's what
happened this guy had a stake in Twitter
Elon went to existing major shareholders
and said will you keep your stake in so
that I can acquire this company and turn
it around at first he was lying nah get
out of here then he was like okay
this is by the way the same Saudi Prince
that has an investment with tens of
millions of dollars with Bill Gates why
is it why is it Bill Gates being
invested by investigated by the federal
government with his Saudi Arabian
collusion especially with his Chinese
collusion especially with his energy
companies especially with his nuclear
companies and his uh you know technology
that's helping the Chinese build uh new
weapons why isn't he being investigated
for that that there's a lot more at
stake with that than than Elon Musk
having a platform where people could now
finally talk to each other there's a big
difference between the two and obviously
this is a a clear action just to try to
hurt Elon Musk here exactly I mean if
you want to Outlaw All Foreign
investment in American companies yeah
let's have that conversation but it's
the selective enforcement that Senator
Murphy I mean obviously they're just
they're trying to
um you know attack a political enemy as
they see mosque is now a political enemy
of the left do you think it would be
righteous to ask the Saudi Prince to
recuse himself from the stock
stockholders of the American companies I
mean in general you think that's a wise
move he's invested in a lot of things in
the United States by the way right and I
mean are we going to single out this one
guy yeah I don't want to say I mean I
would say the Chinese I mean there there
is no Universe in which the Chinese
Communist Party should have any stake in
American companies period American
Farmland American companies like we
should treat them the way we used to
treat the USSR you know during the Cold
War and before that there was Zero
essentially zero trade relationship
between the American government and the
American Marketplace and the Soviet
Marketplace I think there could be some
trade but probably a lot of sanctions
are they an enemy or not I mean that's
the decision we have to make especially
with the uyghur camps that's why I think
this you know my fear is that sanctions
could eventually lead to escalation but
do we just ignore that's that's the
tough thing you got the interventionist
versus anti-interventionist and the
lightest form of it is is still like hey
you're doing a thing we don't like so
we're gonna sanction you but I'm telling
you in Arkansas you know like rural deep
red you know God's country Arkansas we
have a lot of you know chinese-owned
land in our state we have a lot of
Chinese uh Chinese uh oligarchs and
Chinese government investment in our
state we had a a a Chinese native who
was a professor at the University of
Arkansas who was convicted of Espionage
on behalf of the CCP I mean it's
University of Arkansas let me ask you
why should any American citizen have to
compete with the finances of Chinese
oligarchs
if you're in Arkansas if you're in any
state and you want to buy a plot of land
to start a business or as a family why
are you competing in the market with a
foreign country it's a no-brainer I mean
like that shouldn't even be a debate but
like but again like the free market you
know we just we we take these things to
The Logical extreme when it makes no
rational sense I feel like if a guy in
like 1989 was found committing Espionage
against the United States he was a
professor the Chinese was he in Chinese
National he was a Chinese National at
the University of Arkansas that would
have been Global yeah that would have
been like Global News it would have been
on
animosity towards the Chinese which
right now I don't think they want to
create animosity towards the Chinese it
seems like they're varying Cahoots that
they want to sell Taiwan to the Chinese
which by the way you could always sell
eastern Ukraine to the Russians if you
really want to go deep uh and just kind
of peacefully sell out I don't know I
don't think it's a simple better than
conflict so I've always I've always been
concerned about this Saudi Prince's
stake in Twitter the difference between
then and now is then you had a public
company where he was he was pushing his
influence now you have Elon in full
control there's still a question of
whether or not this Saudi Prince is
saying to Elon like I gave you some of
this money so I expect favor something
like that
so the funny thing is you're like I
don't trust this Democrat to actually
have a legitimate investigation but I
think we should know exactly to what
degree the society princess influence on
Twitter well did Elon not pay the 44
billion then he got he got debt
financing he had others uh so this uh
Saudi Prince had this like nearly 2
billion piece of Twitter he said hold on
to that but give me control of the
company but basically like loaning Elon
basically he might get a board seat of
some kind you know that he is well Elon
made himself the sole board member for
now for now he said that's temporary
yeah he tweeted today that it's not
going to be for long that he is just the
sole guy in charge here right I wouldn't
want that pressure either sure and
that's a question like I mean should we
allow a foreign National to be you know
a a board member of even American
private Corporation I mean that's I mean
that's are we serious about this or not
I don't I don't think it's I don't think
it's wise to to have foreign Nationals
if they can't run for office to own our
social networks that we use probably
more than especially how we've just
demonstrated they're not even like free
enterprise private companies anyway
they're federal government proxies yeah
are you against African-American owned
businesses like Twitter Ian is that what
you're trying to say here is that what
you guys are trying to say you caught me
you caught me no I fully support
African-American owned businesses I
think it's I think it's a it's it's it's
a very it's a very complex landscape
it's not easy it's easy I'm all for the
free market but essentially we don't
have a free market we have socialism for
the super rich we have government
intervention with tax incentives with
with subsidies with with them giving
money from the poorest people and giving
it to the biggest corporations that pay
off the politicians so we don't have a
free market system if we did I would
think that this system would of course
fix itself naturally uh with incentives
and and better business practices and
better competition but we don't have any
of that so I think before doing any
before making any laws first we got to
get the government out of business and
the business will fix it there's no real
free market it's a double speak term
like it's always been controlled either
by the people with the money or the
governments now when Andrew Jackson
ruled though well it was probably the
oligarchs at that point like the video
there's I mean robber barons yeah they
call it free market to appease the
masses and they're like don't worry it's
free but when you realize what's
happening it's controlled by the well
the same with Communism right yeah yeah
but look the idea of a free market is I
I don't think anyone if you believe in
the utopian view things you're probably
wrong but in the general sense of a free
market it means that someone from the
lowest close class can find a way to
make money trade and eventually become
the upper echelon and gain significant
control over that system so it's it's
upward mobility in a system as opposed
to uh like a centralized Market yeah or
cash system yeah whenever you have the
government not involved in private
business businesses expand but also
quality of life expands but whenever the
government centralizes a lot of the
stuff as we've seen throughout history
this is this is not always the case but
but correlation historically says less
government more economic freedom more
prosperity for human beings and then the
opposite of that is also true
historically correct because the free
market I mean really all it does is just
harness you know human nature and
people's ability to fix their problems
people acting in their own self-interest
yes and really what I we like I'm not
attacking the free market per se I'm
attacking people arbitraging the system
you know gaming it to essentially be you
know rent-seeking Behavior I mean that
that's what that's what these people are
doing by centralizing power and gaming
the free market to their own advantage
that's what I'm attacking but they're
not gaining a free market they're going
to the government and be like we want to
make sure we have no liability when we
give you this product uh we want to make
sure that no one could sue us if we hurt
people when we when you help us promote
for us and do our PR in making sure
people take our product that's not a
free market at all no that's an
aberration it would originate with like
two guys selling apples and they're like
we're gonna compete whoever wants to buy
my apples at a cheaper price will do
this then eventually the two the two
apple sellers get together and they
collude and they're like yo let's set
the price of apples so then the
government comes in they're like no we
need a free market we're going to make
sure no one violates the law and then
the government sets the laws and sits
there as an Arbiter except now what
you're saying they're like giving people
subsidies not just that the federal
government is selling a product for the
benefit of big Pharma selling it
Shilling it
and then using their Monopoly of
violence in a way to get protection no
matter what happens in the city
liability any liability which is crazy
that's not a free market guys I just
want to give a shout out considering the
episode and the subject matter to all of
the uh feds who are watching and
and uh feel free to you know set the
record straight if this stuff is not
correct or whatever you know you guys
can send emails and and send information
uh project Veritas I'm sure would be
really interested to hear what's really
going on behind the scenes so uh I bet a
lot of people are out of control in
their heads like what do we do what do
we I want to preserve American
constitutionalism we are globalizing it
totally down like a snowball and they're
like what do we do do I just go along
with what what's already been in place
like are we are we coagulating with the
Chinese becoming an Uber State they
don't believe in the Constitution
they believe that this country was
founded not in 1776 but in 1619 they
believe a whole bunch of insane
historical manipulations lies
misinterpretations to justify their
weird cult that's the scary thing so
when they're like in this in this uh in
the meeting report from the story from
The Intercept they're saying things like
people lack critical thinking skills
these days and that's a problem it's
funny because these people writing it
are the example of those who lack
critical thinking skills have you ever
stopped to ask yourself what the next
step in your actions is like you do a
thing what happens next they clearly
don't know they don't think about it
they just think they're smarter than you
they they read garbage fake news believe
it and then they say how come none of
these people believe the garbage that I
believe oh they must be stupid I know
let's censor information and and
manipulate the public opinion these
people are just not smart enough it's
that it's that quote I always forget who
the guy is but he said something like if
the idea is that people aren't smart
enough to govern themselves so a smarter
person you know needs to control them
what makes that person smarter than
anybody else same problem well in the
old C.S Lewis quote I mean he said I'm
butchering it but he essentially said I
don't fear the Tyrant who wants to
torture me I fear the Tyrant who wants
to do something for my own good and
that's what the left is really doing
because I think deep in their hearts you
hook them up to an EKG lie detector they
would tell you they're doing this for
our own good they're censoring this for
our own good because we lack their
critical thinking skills that they have
in Spades and so that's what's so
terrifying is because I think obviously
there are some who are you know sadistic
and just want to hurt people but I think
there is a large portion of the left
that are truly doing this from in their
own work perspective a sense of justice
or a sense of you know do gooderism and
that that to me is so Insidious because
in their hearts they think they are
helping you by crushing your freedom
that's the low level guys in my opinion
I think they're sociopaths on top that
are absolutely calling the shots it's an
army of little guys Bloomberg
said tax the poor you guys remember this
yep in that video he said because
they're too stupid I'm paraphrasing but
too stupid to know it's good for him so
if we take their money from them and
then tell them what they can buy they'll
be better off like when he when he
attacked sugar tax sugary drinks right
you know it's ever look I think sugary
drinks are really bad for you do I think
people should be allowed to have them
sure the problem is a culture where
people understand don't drink a liter of
Cola with your burger and but
Bloomberg's solution is no one should
like tax them punish them for doing it
that's the the dystopian authoritarian
ideology of these people now you see him
and his ilk and how they they take to
the rest of these platforms they think
you know what I'm smarter than you so
I'll be in control and the realities
they're not they're not and that's how
they would approach National divorce in
my mind they would say we can't let them
go their separate ways because we have
to help them
we we we we they would just go harm
themselves or harm others I think there
are a small percentage of people that
need to be guided that if they see two
opposing views that they'll they'll fall
for it but most a lot there's a huge
amount of people that are discernible
that can tell like you give me the
hunter Biden story and the evidence that
shows not well they they those people I
think actually wanted to to hide that
story
but I I they did there was polls showing
that it would it would have swayed and
impacted the election yes
yeah yeah it was it was yeah it was a
decisive censorship yeah it would have
changed our current political landscape
so this is the manipulation of public
perception and support the government
going to Big Tech and let me just come
on guys you know they're going to the
media I can tell you this definitively
how about this I was in Antalya Turkey I
think is the name of the uh of the city
is that is that it is someone look it up
it's like the it's like a Russian Resort
town I guess and um I was there with the
guys from Vice
we are hanging out at uh they were doing
a talk it was all these rich people it
was an organization called wpp what is
it like wire and Plastic Products
something like that who they own a major
portion and all of these companies are
around the world
and uh the CEO of ice explained how
after they went to North Korea they got
a call from the state department and
they had a conversation they talked
about all this stuff I don't think any
he said Shane said anything about them
telling them what to report on but
they're they're in direct communication
over the stories they're doing and he
said something like he told them like
you got to talk to this guy in North
Korea because he was Western educated
and there's like an opportunity so look
man birds of a feather flock together
rich and Powerful it doesn't matter if
you're in Government doesn't matter if
you run a big company powerful Elites
want to hang out with powerful Elites
that's why they have big conferences
every year and they all hang out with
each other in secret
um you know the story that we read in
the beginning of today's broadcast
extremely important and and and really
should make people aware of the larger
manipulation that the government is
conducting behind the closed doors but
if they're doing this to Big Tech social
media what is what do you think they're
doing to the corporate media what do you
think I'll I'll tell you
you may think your favorite reporter is
actually a CIA agent or an FBI agent
with DHS no no no no that's not how it
works the way it works is there will be
a reporter young 24. fresh out of
college gets a job writing for like a
Blog and they're doing you know blog
articles or something
then all of a sudden
they publish this big scoop
their bosses are like whoa how'd you get
this story to have a source
within a few years they go from having
only a few thousand followers on Twitter
to reporting on major breaking stories
about Russia about social media
manipulation Russian disinformation
seemingly just dumping evidence
appearing on MSNBC and these other
channels all of a sudden they say look
we know that Donald Trump did this that
and this fueling the russiagate
narrative
the reality is there's a young
journalist who is stupid
and government actors and agents say hey
I'm going to be a source for you take a
look at this story and then the young
journalist gets all excited whoa this is
a huge scoop they go to their boss I got
a source in the government who just gave
me this document and they go whoa that's
an official U.S government document how
did you get that I have a source how
much money do you want next thing you
know they're being put on TV they're
getting a big salary bump and they're
major stars and news organizations why
because government a actors choose them
to be their conduit for releasing the
stories they want right and it's not
just like that it's a lot more Insidious
especially when you look at the 1975
Church committee meetings that literally
talked about how the intelligence
agencies were at the head of the major
broadcasting companies deciding what
stories they were going to cover and not
cover they were inside of The Newsroom
there's another famous journalist award
winning uh German reporter who worked
for some of the biggest Publications in
the world Udo of Ketty who came out and
said essentially they would send me
articles that I would just put my name
on that they would write for me I was
essentially just regurgitating what the
intelligence agencies wanted me to say
he died under of course mysterious
circumstances but but again this shows
you that that the the government has the
corporate media and it's obvious you
look at their reporting it's not
reporting it's just an establishment
press release they're not reporting on
anything they're they're essentially
trying to set up mind control in a way
that works to their benefit and that is
clear as day when you watch the
corporate media it's not as clear on
social media but it's becoming clearer
by the day when especially with the big
reveal that we just found out about
today when it came to the DHS thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there